Heidi Montag and Spencer Pratt pop by
Lauren Conrad's hometown of Laguna Beach
so we're staying in Newport but we
wanted to come down and see you the
gunner on Tuesday the former stars of
the hills gave a cheeky nod to their one
time reality TV nemesis on snapchat
while the couple who are expecting their
first child together were initially
complimentary of Lauren's hometown it
didn't last long but this isn't the
first time Heidi has visited the Orange
County neighborhood she was a guest star
on Lauren's original MTV hit Laguna
Beach everyone thinks I'm from the
Grenaa Beach but I am NOT I was just on
an episode of Laguna Beach before they
moved to LA start on the hills and had a
falling-out over Heidi's relationship
with Spencer I want to forgive you and I
want to forget you now seven years after
the show wrapped both Lauren and Heidi
are starting families of their own
Lauren welcomed her son Liam with
husband William Tell last week and Heidi
who was in Orange County to do a photo
shoot is six months pregnant with a baby
boy the couple opened up to et in June
about what kind of parents they will be
we're gonna be very loving parents I'm
very strict to I really want to have a
lot of boundaries of their kids
[Music]